so you both share a boyfriend yes I do
oh yeah
oh so that's a bit different yeah
[Music]
we've been with our partner Ben for 11
years the three of us are happy we found
our soulmate we found our Rock our best
friend if we could we will marry Ben if
it's possible we should be able to marry
the same man you know there really
shouldn't be a law like
it's like I don't totally unfair like
we're being judged
but we would like to look into
maybe going overseas and celebrate our
love together where it's possible but at
the moment we're very happy with our
commitment with van and I guess you've
made it this far like this so yeah like
we will not want to change but we're not
this is who we are yeah and it's and Ben
loves us for who we are yes we've found
someone that accepts us for who we are
that's you know there's never been no
jealousy in this relationship Ben treats
us equally he will never kiss Anna and
not me that's happened from day one in
this relationship she just knows to if
he's ever gonna kiss me he kisses Lucy
just straight away he just knows he just
knows truth that's day one in this
relationships it's been equal
it really is true love it really is like
the first night we met him we're like
both kissing like we both kissed him it
wasn't just not at the same time yeah
yeah we both kissed him like a three-way
yeah yeah
this is crazy it's crazy like it's crazy
I
like do they actually really have sex
with the same guy at the same time is it
like one pump two pumps like it's crazy
I don't let him it's wild like I would
never gobble the same because my sister
but I mean like it's weird but like yeah
it is what it is I guess
foreign